vax nevada days wraps up tonight that's
the state's raffle to try and encourage
more of you to get vaccinated against
the pandemic and it concludes with a one
million dollar prize hector mehia live
in the newsroom this morning to break
down what's been handed out so far paper
good morning to you
hey there john good morning well
tonight's announcement wraps up 5
million dollars awarded in either cash
or prizes nearly 2 000 winners and
tonight the big jackpot 1 million
dollars in cash with today being the
last day we caught up with one of the
first winners a clark county school
district teacher
exactly what she won back in early july
elizabeth alder won the first 250 000
prize a teacher for more than two
decades who says she lives paycheck to
paycheck she teaches kindergarten in
north las vegas and says this still
really has not quite set in yet besides
buying school supplies she's also
investing for retirement
pay off
some debt my husband and i we live
modestly we don't
you know we don't go crazy um but it'd
be nice to just be able to do that and
then
we never took a honeymoon so that's our
main goal is to take a honeymoon this
year and then probably buy my mom and
dad a used car
they don't have a running vehicle right
now
alder said she got her vaccine back in
january at unlv before vax nevada days
was even announced she says she loves
her job and that her heart is in
kindergarten tonight's final
announcement is at 6 p.m at the las
vegas convention center bringing
governor steve sisilak along with other
elected leaders we'll carry that here on
8 news now reporting live hector mejia
back to you